[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo ante la situación de kobe 19
ahora trabajamos desde casa pueda que
parezca normal ver como aumenta el
número de cámaras de vigilancia en las
calles aeropuertos y servicios de
transporte público incluso aquellas que
usan reconocimiento facial y que
estarían destinadas a ayudar a combatir
la delincuencia pero cada vez son más
los cuestionamientos sobre el verdadero
propósito de estas herramientas y su
efectividad un informe de una serie de
ong reveló como gobiernos de américa
latina' ción excusaba en la seguridad
pública para desplegar tecnología de
vigilancia masiva la misma que se ha
usado para espionaje y violaciones a los
derechos humanos la falta de
transparencia y responsabilidad con que
se utilizan generan preocupaciones
empezamos
el uso de herramientas que recopilan
datos biométricos como patrones faciales
o huellas digitales hacen parte de
nuestro día a día por ejemplo la usamos
para realizar transacciones desbloquear
nuestro teléfono celular y cada vez más
se integran a las cámaras de vigilancia
que vemos en las calles una
investigación conjunta de las ong access
nado el laboratorio de políticas
públicas e internet de brazil la
asociación por los derechos civiles en
argentina y la libre puntonet en
ecuador' detalló como gobiernos de
américa latina han desplegado equipos de
vigilancia bajo la excusa de la
seguridad pública la preocupación no
radica sólo en la cantidad de equipos de
monitoreo o cámaras sino en el propósito
con el que fueron instaladas pues
permiten identificar seguir y rastrear a
las personas donde quiera que vayan
denuncian que aunque existen leyes de
protección de datos algunas resultan
insuficientes para proteger a los
ciudadanos de la vigilancia estatal el
documento señala también que el uso de
estas herramientas se lleva a cabo sin
ningún tipo de transparencia o
responsabilidad así lo cuenta verónica
arrolló asociada de políticas públicas
para américa latina de access net
al final nosotros estamos siendo
identificados nuestras actividades
pueden ser trazadas y jamás tuvimos un
espacio para consentir que esto suceda
es uno de los problemas más graves y eso
es un problema muy serio para nosotros
en américa latina es que viola nuestro
principio de presunción de inocencia es
un principio básico básico dentro del
debido proceso porque la mayoría de
estos sistemas como decíamos en una
narrativa de seguridad pública es porque
quieren encontrar a aquellos aquellas
personas que están perseguidas por la
justicia pero para encontrar más
justicia lo que están haciendo es
vigilar los a todos ya todas el informe
se centra en argentina brasil y ecuador
por ser los países de la región donde
existe una mayor cantidad de
implementación de este tipo de
tecnologías el panorama es el siguiente
en argentina opera el mayor número de
estas empresas la investigación detalló
el despliegue de equipos de vigilancia y
monitoreo fabricado por unas 12
compañías la gran mayoría extranjeras
tecnologías como el reconocimiento
facial se utilizan en aeropuertos
servicios de transporte público y en las
calles de varias ciudades aunque no está
claro cuál ha sido el alcance de estos
sistemas en brásil la investigación pudo
identificar que se usan los servicios de
vigilancia y tecnología de
reconocimiento facial de al menos cinco
grandes empresas extranjeras estas
herramientas que se usan principalmente
en aeropuertos del país también se han
utilizado en varios eventos públicos por
ejemplo se aprobó durante el carnaval de
río de 2019 y según las autoridades
pertinentes se capturaron unos tres
millones de rostros de los cuales se
identificaron a unas ocho mil personas
de interés entre prófugos y sospechosos
además se realizaron diez capturas pero
estas tecnologías no están exentas de
fallas medios de comunicación informaron
que en la misma ciudad durante la copa
américa de 2019 una mujer fue confundida
con la autora de un asesinato quien ya
se encontraba en la cárcel y que otro
hombre fue detenido durante varios días
después de ser erróneamente identificado
a las ong les preocupa que además de la
falta de precisión el sistema de
reconocimiento facial se dirige
desproporcionadamente a personas de piel
oscura según una investigación de
organizaciones de derechos humano
pasamos ahora a ecuador donde de acuerdo
con el documento se utiliza a gran
escala equipos de vigilancia que
solamente dos empresas extranjeras pero
no por eso el panorama es menos sombrío
estos equipos están integrados a un
sistema de vigilancia policial creado en
2010 para combatir la delincuencia
llamado eco 911 que controla más de 6000
cámaras en todo el país según access
negó una investigación del diario
estadounidense the new york times' en
2019 reveló que el eco 911 fue utilizado
por el gobierno del ex presidente rafael
correa para perseguir y acosar
opositores en presunta complicidad con
la antigua secretaria nacional de
inteligencia el ex presidente de lenin
moreno la eliminó en 2018 y en su
reemplazo creó el centro de inteligencia
estratégica pese a esta historial el eco
911 sigue vigente el documento recopila
casos en los que las tecnologías
vendidas por algunas de estas empresas
se han utilizado para cometer abusos
contra los derechos humanos como por
ejemplo las empresas chinas hype visión
y dawa cuyas tecnologías operan en
argentina brasil y ecuador
y los proyectos de vigilancia para la
región de xinjiang en china donde se
cree que el gobierno tiene detenidos en
campos de concentración a un millón de
personas de la minoría musulmana uigur
en diciembre de 2020 la organización
ipbm descubrió un documento que
demostraría que huawei otra empresa
china reconocida a nivel mundial que
presta servicios en argentina y brasil-
hizo pruebas con un software de
inteligencia artificial para reconocer a
los uigures y alertar a la policía algo
que el gobierno chino calificó como una
calumnia
este nuevo informe sobre vigilancia se
produce casi un mes después de que se
revelara que periodistas activistas y
jefes de estado en decenas de países
estaban siendo espiados a través de
pegasus un programa que fue creado para
combatir el crimen y que durante años se
vende a gobiernos de todo el mundo
asesinados recuerda que américa latina
tiene un largo historial de persecución
de disidentes y comunidades marginadas y
que esta es la receta perfecta para que
haya una expansión y abuso de
tecnologías de vigilancia
hasta aquí en revista digital recuerde
que si quiere repetir esta u otra
emisión de nuestro programa lo puede
hacer a través de nuestra página web www
punto 4